uh we got this guy already kind of
what's this burn victim oh my god
bro what are you talking about this is a
great young man
no you're right man do you want to hear
the options
huh let's go with this let's ride with
this guy from obviously from
is this your buddy got left out in the
sun on heroin
no his name's sean and that's not him
and sorry sean but i didn't say your
last name but also
anybody who knows you is going to know
it's you bro
and i love you i'm just guessing you're
not talking about sean o'malley he was
just talking about wanting to try heroin
a clip went viral really yeah that's
awesome well
that boy gave me some trouble with that
was he yeah he was holding his he was
holding his child
on his podcast yeah and that's good and
then they and then they went hard at
megan anderson which i
i don't support that who's that the
woman yeah
who's that his wife no she's a female
ufc fighter in case she's playing amanda
nunes she's a badass
wow australian girl really talented man
i like that dutch girl who was so good
and then she came out all frenetic last
time and got smoked
two fights ago by that uh it was like a
young black woman i think oh yeah you're
talking about uh maria agapova
versus shanna dobson she like gassed
herself out she's like she's got like uh
gauged ears and stuff and she's like
yeah she's always like she's spunky
yeah she does too many punches towards
the camera in the beginning yeah it's
like just do it once
yeah this guy looks
insane what's up
thesaurus and bernard i gotta
sting it or king it for you
that korean kicker kimchi
what do you say is that a redhead
stinging her king yet king and sting it
bang bang guys guys dude is this the
doctor from the girl that got bit by the
shark where's that guy eating
look man first of all you seem like a
great guy
i want to say that man out the gate you
got that hat you got that body those
tits oh that's what is that
oh that's her cheeky like yeah
i love that girl man i can't believe i
did the kimchi without
chin here though yeah he wouldn't have
added anything
[Laughter]
last episode he said three words he
doesn't talk on any of my shows
i think something's going on uh
he's thinking about killing me but if he
killed you it would be
that would be all i mean it'd be
unfortunate but it would be
unprecedented yeah it wouldn't be good
but it'd be crazy think about it like
the first like the you know ever since
like david spade got attacked by his
by his uh that's right assistant that's
right he
tied him up and tased him and [ __ ] we'd
all be characters in a movie for sure
oh yeah called making a podcaster
who would play you you think in the
movie pride taylor
or joey fatone
almost maybe joey fat
enjoy fat tone yeah joey oh yeah
broadway oh yeah wait like an
off-broadway joyful tone way off bro
we're talking cincinnati yeah yeah i'm
talking about cleveland broadway wow
dude
wow yeah that's my dad
uh joey for sounds [ __ ] awesome dude
i could that even look like him on the
left
i look how hairy his arms are it's rough
that his last name actually spells fat
one
oh that's tough that's a rock justin
timberlake
justin timberlake said i gotta get away
from these [ __ ] [ __ ]
they dude joseph like always looks
exhausted doesn't he yeah he's dancing
all the time
um so then what i would say is um
jesus christ i would say king it man
what is this guy talking about uh kimchi
not my thing hard sting bro yeah what is
it cabbage and hot sauce
yeah it's like an asian cabbage and hot
sauce
and look it's easy to say that in
america where we have you know they have
a lot of food here
you know america it's like you can you
can't have food we'll give you food you
can't have house we'll give you you know
there's no everybody gets a [ __ ] can
of [ __ ] you know
bean and wieners dogs so um
i think that yeah in other places you
got to make what
whatever whatever's left you got to make
something good a lot of times they use
spicy
so you go to india bro they'll say like
you should have this beef spice and it's
just like a
broth and it's like it tastes like beef
kind of but it's like not like didn't
have any meat you know so you just
eating different
you know they put they write the word
beef on it it's just something suit i
don't know what you're talking about
but i'm saying in some places this [ __ ]
started in [ __ ] korea dog
yeah i don't [ __ ] with that at all i i
mean chin's ball deep in it
yeah china eat uh commit what's called
kimchi
kimchi and uh sardines for lunch uh oh
yeah and it smells like [ __ ]
eats sardines all every day that was my
secret santa gift from him
that's right really
my brother eats sardines and it always
made me think that we weren't even
brothers
that makes sense disgusting when they
open a little can they're all in there
it's like a little
it looks like one of those grave sites
from like world war one it's a
concentration camp for [ __ ] sardines
dude you open it up and they're all just
yeah then you eat them
all of it eyes ears
disgusting [ __ ] hard stinging on
kimchi
yeah but i dig ginger heart sting on the
holocaust heart seeing on kimchi
facts but it is definitely yeah it's
like but look here's the thing though i
think it's just an acquired taste like a
lot of you know
a lot of japanese people don't like
mustard you know it's just
that's the thing it's like some some
things they just don't like in some
places
yeah you know a lot of uh russians don't
like popcorn did you know that
why they just don't it's not it's too
soft
it's just like hard [ __ ] bro popcorn's
for [ __ ]
it really is russians want that hard
[ __ ] sausage in their mouth you know
that than brats then german brats yes
vodka calm down okay
nick wow talking about uh do you guys
eat it your girlfriends uh
i'll try like when you go to korean
barbecue they have like all the stuff in
the beginning and kimchi is one of them
and i'll
usually have some like eel and [ __ ] nick
if it's there i'll like try it but like
i'm pretty much
i'll eat anything if people put it in
front of me but i'll stay in my comfort
zone if i'm left to choose for myself
wisconsin bro stay in your lane
yeah cheese milk potatoes i might be
right but the eight man a lot of the
asians they'll do like
i'm sucking eye off a catfish bro i saw
a girl
eat like a decent look good-looking girl
eating a talon of something out of a bag
on a train
and it smelled so bad yeah i just
couldn't even believe
someone was allowed to eat it like
literally had you hot it was
doug i've seen she's [ __ ] eating it
had a skin and
it didn't even clean the fingernails on
it doug i i ordered wings
from wing stop for the crew and chin ate
the bones
yeah like the ear the like you know how
you eat a wing eat the bone throat chin
eats
sucks the [ __ ] mirror out the middle
then chews on the bone
dude yeah a lot of chinese you know
they're really
they're kind of they're the african
americans of the eastern hemisphere yeah
that's fair
would you guys try the geoduck if we got
some in here
yeah i'd detailed that thing come on man
why do y'all do this every time
nothing busts what are y'all doing are
they no
is this still alive when you're eating
it
oh yeah hell yeah girl slap that thing
around we're missing our experts i'm not
sure
no but didn't even add anything last
time did we learn anything
no they've never tried it either hey man
yeah uh
you know i feel like
that's all i got that's all i got
[Music]